hey 42 here as you know the universe
follows a predictable format it contains
galaxies galaxies contain solar systems
and solar systems contain all of the
planets this General Galactic structure
is one of the first things we learn
about space as kids and it's completely
wrong because it turns out that planets
aren't just found inside solar systems
some known as rogue planets don't orbit
stars at all they just drift around out
there alone in the vast emptiness of
space and what we're about to uncover
about them not only rewrites our Cosmic
rule book but as you'll find out by the
end of this video completely changes the
search for extraterrestrial life and
what it means to be
human all those rogue planets drifting
alone out there in the Solitude of space
with their unpredictable paths not
knowing where their future will lead
reminds me of my struggles during the
festive season when it comes to managing
stress and keeping on top of my busy
workload it's a very paradoxical time of
year we should all be coming together
but like rogue planets some of us end up
feeling more alone than ever before but
stress and the low moods that come with
it aren't just a seasonal issue and the
earlier you can recognize it in your own
thought patterns the sooner you can
enact positive change so better help
joined me in a paid partnersh ship for
this video better help is an easyto use
platform with a vast network of over
30,000 therapists providing a convenient
way to seek professional help especially
during a hectic period like right now
better helps questionnaire helps match
you with a therapist who can better
understand your unique struggles with
stress and holiday pressures so the
therapy you receive feels very personal
to you in most cases you can get matched
with a therapist in 48 hours or less and
it's really reassuring that if the
therapist you're matched with isn't a
good fit you can switch your therapist
with no additional cost if you're
struggling this holiday season or Beyond
I encourage you to take steps to talk to
someone and join the 4 million people
who are using better help to live
happier healthier lives click the link
in the description below to get 10% off
your first month and using my link also
really helps to support the channel now
I know what you're thinking just because
a few planets exist outside solar
systems it doesn't mean our whole view
of the cosmos is completely wrong but
get ready for random interesting facts
time because it isn't just a few planets
that have gone Rogue according to
researchers at both NASA and Osaka
University there are approximately six
times as many rogue planets in our
galaxy as there are regular ones and 20
times as many
stars if that ratio is correct that
means there are around 2 trillion rogue
planets in our galaxy
alone the problem with numbers like that
is there literally impossible for our
puny human brains to comprehend so let
me help you to visualize what two
trillion planets really looks like if
all the rogue planets in the Milky Way
were grains of sand they would fill four
entire shipping
containers if that doesn't blow your
mind I'm worried you don't have a mind
to blow rogue planets aren't the
exception they're the rule and with so
many of them knocking around I can't
help but Wonder could they Harbor
life intuitively it feels like the
answer to that question should be a hard
no a planet without a host star would
receive practically zero external energy
it would be a frigid empty wasteland
about as welcoming to life as the
reactor room in shobal in April of
1986 or would it well not necessarily
because it turns out that not only could
rogue planets be habitable they might
just be seeding the entire universe with
Life as we
speak rogue planets are created in one
of two ways the first kind formed just
like stars from the collapse of colossal
clouds of dust and gas but they never
gain enough Mass to kick off nuclear
fusion within their cause and are
instead doomed to wander the cosmos for
eternity knowing that they never truly
lived up to their potential the second
group form like regular planets in
boring old solar systems but at some
point the gravity of a larger Planet
yeets them out into empty space with
such Force they escape the gravity of
their parent star and just keep going
young solar systems are chaotic places
and scientists now think that this sort
of unseemly Planet yeting behavior is
actually extremely common which means
there's a good chance our own planet has
a long lost sibling or two somewhere out
there in the endless darkness of
space
so with all these newly suspected
planets to explore what are the chances
of one of them containing alien life if
you want to bake a life cake you need
fre ingredients a variety of chemical
elements a solvent of some kind in our
case water and an energy
source the first part should be pretty
easy the so-called chemical building
blocks of life elements like carbon
hydrogen oxygen nitrogen sulfur and
phosphorus are abundant all over the
universe so we'd expect to find them on
Plenty of rogue planets the second two
parts not so much here on Earth we get
both of them from the Sun it provides
living things with energy and keeps the
planet warm enough to support liquid
water without a parent star a rogue
planet is going to need some other
source of energy to fulfill those roles
the question is what the sun is the
major energy provider here on Earth by a
huge margin but it isn't the only energy
provider oh whopping
0.027% of Earth's energy budget comes
from within the planet itself partly
from the decay of radioactive materials
and partly in the form of heat left over
from Earth's formation 4 and a half
billion years
ago on its own this geothermal energy
wouldn't be anywhere near enough to keep
a starless planet warm but if that
planet had a dense atmosphere of some
kind of greenhouse gas it could theore
ically trap enough heat to warm things
up quite nicely according to a study
published in 1999 a hydrogen atmosphere
around 100 times denser than our own
would be so effective at trapping
geothermal heat it would generate
surface temperatures toasty enough to
support liquid water oceans that's a
promising start and geothermal energy
isn't the only thing that can keep a
rogue Planet
warm it's easy to assume that rogue
planets are lone wonderers
in fact that's kind of implied but just
like regular planets there's no reason
they couldn't have moons as you probably
know the gravitational tug of our own
moon is largely responsible for Oceanic
Tides but it isn't just water that feels
the pull of the moon it's everything a
large moon will literally stretch and
compress its parent planet in what
highlight to think of as a big incestous
gravitational massage all that intimate
gravity based touching causes friction
and friction
generates heat we see this in action
right here in our very own solar system
moons like Europa and Enceladus
experience extreme tidal forces from
gravitational interactions between their
massive parent planets Jupiter and
Saturn and their respective moons as a
result and despite being well outside of
what's traditionally considered the
habitable zone of our solar system both
generate enough internal heat to support
subsurface oceans beneath thick layers
of surface
[Music]
so between geothermal heat and friction
from tidal forces we can confidently say
that we should find liquid water on some
rogue planets or even their moons but
what about the energy needed to power
living things until relatively recently
scientists were under the impression
that every single living organism on
Earth relied on the sun's energy for
nourishment in other words they thought
that the bottom of every single food
chain was populated by some kind of
photosynthesizer converting energy from
the Sun into food if that were true it
would be a bit of a problem for a roog
planet billions of miles from the
nearest star but luckily it isn't in
1977 scientists researching deep SE
hydrothermal vents discovered something
remarkable bacteria were feeding on the
rich chemical soup spewing out of events
and turning it into food it was the same
basic concept as phot photos symphysis
only with chemicals as the input instead
of sunlight today we know this process
as chemos symphysis and we can be
confident it's a perfectly viable energy
source to power life because it supports
entire ecosystems of diverse creatures
right here on Earth both around
hydrothermal vents and cold seeps on the
ocean floor and in C and cave
systems okay so some Rogue Planet should
have the right chemistry for Life some
should have liquid water in oceans
either on or beneath the surface and
some should have access to energy
sources capable of sustaining life now
considering how many rogue planets there
are out there it seems extremely likely
that some are going to be habitable
that's an intriguing Prospect and it
might just explain one of the biggest
mysteries in all of science the origin
of life on Earth for dead matter to
suddenly turn into living matter quite a
lot of seemingly very unlikely things
needed to happen amino acids had to band
together in extremely specific ways to
form proteins long strings of various
molecules had to somehow self organize
into forms that were capable of
replicating themselves and the first
cell membranes had to spontaneously
Cobble themselves together to keep all
those various bits and pieces in one
place none of these things are
impossible possible self organization in
disordered systems seems to be a feature
of our universe but each of those steps
occurring in just the right way to give
birth to life seems so vanishingly
unlikely that it's really hard to
believe it ever happened the missing
ingredient here is probably time given
enough of it even the most unlikely
things can happen it's your classic
monkey typing Shakespeare sort of deal
give him a weekend and you'll end up
with several pages of utter nonsense but
give him a few billion years and before
you know it he's wondering what light
through yonder window
breaks but there's a small problem with
that theory our planet is 4.5 billion
years old and according to our current
best estimates life first appeared here
at least 3.7 billion years ago and maybe
as many as 4.2 billion years
ago either way things got going
surprisingly quickly and once they got
going early organisms got complex very
past to some scientists that just
doesn't add up a few hundred million
years simply isn't enough time for a
molecular monkey to bash out a living
organism and yet we know for certain
that life was here so what gives well
there are a few possible answers to that
question perhaps the steps required to
create life from non-living matter are a
lot more likely than we think they are
some scientists even believe they're
inevitable maybe we just got insanely
lucky and landed ourselves a genius
monkey that smashed out the complete
works of Shakespeare on his very first
try or perhaps life on Earth has been
evolving for much longer than we think
it has and it's here that rogue planets
might come into
[Music]
play according to the theory of pans
spermia life didn't necessarily
originate on planet Earth at all it
traveled here from elsewhere in the
cosmos if that were true Earth life
might be billions of years older than
previously thought that would go a long
way to explaining how life got going so
soon after the formation of the planet
and how early Earth life achieved such
surprising complexity in the first few
hundred million years after it
appeared one of the biggest problems
with the panspermia theory has
traditionally been the question of how
exactly the seeds of Life crossed the
vast distances between the Stars
space dust or asteroids are two of the
most commonly suggested dispersal
mechanisms but any life hitching a lift
on either of those would be exposed to
the incredible hostile environment that
is naked space but what if life's been
traveling around the universe in much
Cozier circumstances all along could a
passing Rogue planet have seeded Earth
with Life 4 billion years ago might we
all be aliens on an alen world without
even knowing it okay so we're well into
the realm of wild speculation here but
it's a hell of an idea all the
same when we look for life out there in
the universe we tend to search for
conditions that are as close to our own
as possible an orphaned Planet cruising
through the darkness of space billions
of miles from the nearest star is about
as difference to planet Earth as it's
possible to be and yet by some estimates
rogue planets are home to more more
habitable real estate than can be found
anywhere else in our galaxy and that
makes them incredibly important as of
today they're still poorly understood
for obvious reasons they're difficult to
detect and that makes them hard to study
it seems extremely likely that some
rogue planets will prove to be habitable
but for now it's impossible to say for
sure just how many the good news is if
just one in a 100,000 turn out to have
the right conditions for life that
that's still 20 million habitable rogue
planets zipping around our galaxy and
who knows these lonely Wanderers might
just be our universe's silent Farmers
sewing the seeds of Life wherever they
go thanks for
watching just a quick word to say that I
couldn't make these videos without the
support of my patreon members consider
joining the exclusive 42 Discord
Community by by supporting me on patreon
it's a great place to discuss my videos
with like-minded individuals and myself
the Link's in the description but if you
don't want to or you can't join my
patreon then please don't worry a simple
like or comment to say thanks would also
put a huge smile on my face thank you